this video is brought to you by
manscape.com
pow we know that guys are impossible to
shop for the holidays
luckily manscape has the gifts that keep
on giving we're talking about
the manscape performance package an
all-in-one grooming kit from head to toe
man maintenance
it comes with a weed whacker a trimmer
design for your nose and ear hairs
every man needs to add this to their
grooming regimen by the way i need to
use it right now because i got dangling
nose hairs
you hear that it's working i need some
tuna okay
you heard that it's working yep thank
you you get the lawnmower
3.0 a waterproof cordless trimmer
that's safe enough to trim around your
ballsackeries
look at this one oh there's a light
so you can shine a light on that ball
sack the lawnmower 3.0 is perfect
for using in the shower because that's
why i use it all the time so you don't
have to deal with the
aftermath of a freshly trimmed tree if
you know what the hell i mean
the performance package comes with
everything you see here plus two
free gifts it comes with the shed travel
bag
and the manscaped anti-chafing
box of briefs this is what it looks like
very soft
very smooth every guy out here needs to
add manscape to your wishlist this
season
and use our link www.manscape.com
jknews to get additional 20 off plus
free international shipping
the link will be in the description
below pop it be puppy
your jingle balls will thank you
[Music]
all right guys i have this freaking
funny and infuriating story for the
woman involved in here
infuriating for us or only for her
uh it's funny for us yeah infuriating
let's see what happens she's not the bad
guy she's the victim
so [ __ ] the other people all right so
this story here she's
so this wife she is pregnant um
her and her husband have this dog named
jerry and i like him an absolute
sweetheart
and she loves them very dearly okay
about five weeks ago uh they were having
they were eating dinner and then
suddenly the wife smelled something
really disgusting and so the husband
instantly made a face so he so then like
letting her know that he also smelled it
and so try to pass it off and so um she
said that she couldn't stand the smell
and left the room and then later in bed
her husband told her that the dog farted
okay
sure she said that the smell was
unbelievable it smelled like rotten eggs
and she thought it was a one-off because
the dog farts
just like they do and but it's just
never been that bad
but then she just was like okay whatever
so then over the next week
the smell would come again and again at
random times what the hell oh so it
wasn't like consistent
at random times yeah oh wow and then so
she would like candles
incense nothing worked out yeah [ __ ]
it's happening in this house
get those christmas cinnamon pinecones
oh those are all those are good
very good very good betty swag very
punchy
yeah and then so the whole time she
thought it was the dog and then so she
said okay i'm gonna take him to the vet
like a fart this smelly just
can't be normal i think the husband's
starting to take protein shakes so then
the husband like throw out this whole
time the husband was quiet
and then so she takes the dog to the vet
and then the vet
recommended the dog have a diet change
oh no
but the horrific smell continued and so
she said that she was losing her mind so
they put the dog down
what no but her dog i mean
her husband kept still kept his mouth
shut
and so the vet was extremely confused
ordered a bunch of tests that cost a lot
of money poor dog
too and then the whole time the husband
wasn't saying [ __ ] nothing all this
getting poked and getting blood he's
dead he's dealing him out he's probably
farting like a mobile
dude he's having egg salad sandwiches at
lunch so then the test all showed that
the dog was perfectly fine
and then that's when the wife remembers
she's pregnant her
anxiety started to kick in and she was
like oh my god what if something's wrong
with him what if we lose him
she ended up reaching a breaking point
she had a full-on like panic attack like
a meltdown
about losing jerry the dog and
and then so she had a miscarriage no no
okay and then so
she was just like just hysterical right
and then
finally at that point is when the
husband confessed that the farts were
his not the dog he never tried to change
anything about what he was doing
i know yeah like if it started out of
nowhere he didn't always have it
house we're not asking the right
question how scary is this woman
that he can't even admit to his farts
that's a good point
she is pregnant too so that's a really
really good idea no no how stupid is
this man
where he thinks hiding it from his wife
is gonna be smarter than just
confronting uh uncomfortable no it's
always the scary wife the scary wife is
more bullying [ __ ] man you're [ __ ]
a little bit unbelievable
no one wants to admit that that's not
being a [ __ ] taking the dog to the vet
spending thousands of dollars just like
[ __ ] that builds
and this [ __ ] [ __ ] isn't saying
anything he deserves
what happened next oh what happened she
says then the joke went too far
divorced then she said like she's like i
lost it i
kicked him out of the house he went to
stay with friends so then
um tell his friends he's like the
[ __ ] dog man
that's so good that [ __ ] dog's
farting
that dog fart ruined my life
dude and then it's so so then she said
she was like he knew we were going to
the vet like
the vet that's some [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
went to the vet appointments with
her oh i feel so bad believe this [ __ ]
yeah it's crazy
laughing internally or he was just
[ __ ] dying inside this dog just
getting [ __ ] blood drawn
x-rays all kinds of his butt getting
prodded all the time he's all standing
there with his starbucks like damn
he's like god no dude he's drinking
[ __ ] protein shakes yeah he's
drinking a protein shake
no and then so so then she writes that
his mother
his mother was on her side as well and
she called him an
idiot and so finally eventually they're
reconciled
and but she says that she's still too
angry to get over it
that he he's a [ __ ] idiot how does he
admit it is he like he's like
you know when i said that lassie did it
uh
jerry he's like that was i dealt it
i [ __ ] it at least i was being honest
wait how he was lying about this no i'm
saying
that that's what he owed that he finally
did it
he had to change his diet or something
right because like oh yeah
weren't the farts before she was
pregnant oh yeah so then he ends up
going to the doctor
for his farts and then the doctor
recommends the same thing which is a
diet change
um this was so dumb yeah so then did
they find out what it was though that's
what i wanted i don't know
how does he not make one diet change
this whole egg solid salad
something's starting he's having egg
salad sandwiches with eggnog for lunch
[Laughter]
money's going down a drain i don't know
what's wrong see i just discovered these
sandwiches and i can't stop
this eggnog is so good just perfect
[Laughter]
dude i don't know man that poor wife man
and that poor baby
the baby's all stressed yeah now because
the baby also has dumb ass dad
exactly now she's like oh god my baby's
gonna be half done
oh yeah yeah and half smelly oh yeah
yeah so then ready but the users were
commenting
uh justice for justice for jerry yeah
four dogs and then another one said that
was so cruel to the dog
and then someone else said how many
times did the vet draw blood for these
tests and man stressing out your
pregnant wife for no reason
is just putting your baby at risk i love
how he just blames the dog
i don't know he keeps farting dude also
okay this is the most inconsiderate
thing he knows that his his nuclear
farts are like affecting his wife
he doesn't leave the room ever yeah yeah
he doesn't go outside he just rips
a butt cheek hello there's no sound
that's why it has to be like he had to
start it as a joke and then it just got
too far to the point where he's
like he was laughing inside so it was
just easier for him to fart and then
just
he's like i get this dumb [ __ ] taking
the dog to the vet
but it's your your money too down the
drain yeah it is yeah that's
dumb that's the part that angers me the
most me too the deals
yeah that's true blazing that money away
yeah
because i think if she made a vet
appointment i would have been like
before we waste our money
yeah you know hold on hold on that's
true i've been cranking it big
time now he let this [ __ ] go on for five
weeks
look i respect the amount of time don't
get me wrong
you're a color blind foreign a year a
whole year
this guy it's a whole different thing
have you got a commitment in a minute
have you guys blamed a fart on a dog
before no ever
i have of course of course i have it's
the people who don't fart in front of
the significant others who have who have
done it exactly right
i mean i i do both but i think it's
funny when you have a dog to blame it on
not even a cat how do cat farts smell
cat farts are pretty rough actually
i've smelled my cat's fart once and yeah
it was pretty crazy they're pretty nuts
yeah i think dog burps are worse than
dog parts they burp too
yeah i've never really purposely farted
with the intent to blame it on my dog
no no i did like it'll be like i'm in a
room by myself with a dog
and i'm like i'm by myself let's go a
fart and then she comes in the room i'm
like gosh
that's not fair you weren't supposed to
come in yet yeah that's not fair so then
she comes in and she's like did the
you don't stop him did he i stop him if
i hear some steps wait
no i appreciate that no i mean it takes
like it takes like a couple minutes to
air out so it's not like a fresh one as
she's coming in it's like coming out
it's like how far
and after like a full minute she'll
enter the room and it hasn't fully
cleared yet it's the worst and i'm like
still lingering
oh [ __ ] but then it's not like i'll
blame it on him i just go along with it
so she'll be like same as this
did he fart and i'm like i guess so
that's weird
but you also sometimes can't like stop
them if they're excited like
oh my god he can't believe what i just
saw i'm like what and oh my god what the
[ __ ] is that
i couldn't stop you
but nelson it was a dog when your chick
is in the room and she
she and you're like oh yeah i guess it
was the dog huh and then she leaves the
room
you're like george clooney at the end of
[ __ ] ocean's eleven
you're like walking out with the
briefcase you're like
oh i just pulled a caper man
[ __ ] [ __ ] here did it again you guys
never been
so deep into your imagination that you
forget that other people are in the room
and you rip one
no tomorrow
i mean i did it a couple of times here
have you ever farted so hard that it
took you out of your own imagination and
back to reality
usually because i fart and i look up and
i'm like oh [ __ ] my bad
it's like when you wake yourself up from
a snore oh
yeah it was before or from a fart it
happens to me
you wake yourself up from my heart i've
done that before that's pretty strong
damn
it's because you save it that's why i
save them that's right at night
yeah i don't fart just whenever i just
fart like
in the bathroom only when you're
sleeping and when i'm sleeping damn
you have payload casey's like wow this
bed massages me at night it's kind of
weird
i forgot who it was but he was getting
in trouble for farting at
while sleeping who i forgot who it was
but his girl was mad at him
because he would fart in the middle of
the night and he's like i can't [ __ ]
control that
i got i got in trouble for farting in
the hot tub well for your parts you
shouldn't afford anything it's safe
right
no it [ __ ] comes up and it explodes
it goes like this yeah geyser i didn't
think the bubbles would go that way
bro you got it you had yosemite dude
what the [ __ ] no did you know that in
water like in humid spaces or whatever
like in the shower
you you're able to smell better like
it's more really clears your sinuses
yeah so
so when you fart in the shower where you
fart in pretty bad it smells even more
i know but i thought it was going that
way you know he knows now
he got in trouble he had to experiment
before
i thought it smelled worse in the shower
because i was trapped in that container
with it
that's the way yeah i mean the only
reason why i know is because i farted in
the jacuzzi
by myself so i experimented and i said
that's wrong that's right
you have solutions when you find the
shower i open up the shower door all
right i just let it rip
i'm like yeah i just i don't want to be
trapped in it so i'm like all right get
out that way and then i close it again
oh really by myself i'm like stay over
there i just suffer in it and i'm like
i deserve this that's how i feel
i'm a guilty catholic i kind of stand
there just kind of like damn i produce
that yeah i just sing louder and try to
rely on other senses like my ears you
sing
louder it just makes it even louder and
harder oh
harmonize with it yeah
[Music]
you